Disney logos gotten pretty goddamn full
of itself I wish and in this village
narrator commits a couple of sins here
which we are duly going to count because
that guy first off and most importantly
he interrupts Anna Kendrick nobody puts
Baby in a corner
face second off narration in general
face more than life more than jewels a
carefree young lass isn't nice that
Cinderella properly stops her song so
that an invisible narrator can continue
his stupid she also I'm not sure I can
follow everything with us back and forth
this plot narration sing-along is too
complex well if the count gives you some
milk then you can get the cheese but cow
can't just straight up give you cheese
what kind of a wish is that you might as
well wish for a million dollars while
you're at it yeah to go to the festival
is why it's a bad idea to sing your
dreams out loud
especially if you're an indentured
servant orphan girl whose host family
hates our guts the festival the king's
festival actors are playing for the back
row which is odd considering we're in a
movie theatre right now and then there
was a hungry little girl who always wore
a red cape probably a superhero probably
will be in the next Avengers movie and
let's be honest into the woods is sort
of an Avengers for fairytales so no one
will be able to tell the difference it's
not for me it's for my granny in the
woods song intended to excuse
shoplifting even in the live-action
version Cinderella needs birds to help
her kick Kurvers sift through the ashes
into the pop bird slavery wanna whizzes
with a wig huh someone got paid to feel
clever for writing this line sometimes I
wonder what's going on in that head of
yours but then my abusive nature takes
over and I stop getting it into the
woods it's time to go roll credits and
gladly okay I know damn girl we already
rolled your credits you can stop saying
it my back to the sky if only you could
use that beautiful singing voice to get
them to peck your stepmother and
stepsisters dies out seems reasonable
who's going to convict you for that well
yes your honor Cinderella has the power
to make birds murder people prosecution
rests
even if you hate someone with all your
being how is this that funny town and
they dragged meryl streep into this
didn't they what she wanted more than
anything in the world was grains grains
nothing but greens salad loving girl
completely derails fairy tale story via
salad loving he was robbing me raping me
um robbing is right
the other thing probably not but maybe
this movie is way darker than I
previously thought I had a brother no
sister and you'll never find well
considering I just learned about her how
broken up can you expect me to be she
would punish me with the curse of
ugliness if I ever lost any of them
which plays the pronoun game so that the
Baker's wife has to ask what the hell
them means special beans I let him go I
didn't know he'd stolen my beans which
his mother put a curse on her looks tied
to magic beans that don't do anything
but grow in a garden outside somehow
they get stolen that curse still kicks
in there's no gray area in the world of
stupid magical curses into the woods to
sell vac app this movie has ruled credit
stick till about a dozen times and we're
literally not even to the 12 minute mark
one the cow as white as milk to the Cape
as red as blood well isn't it amazing
that in all the stories we've been
following so far those exact things are
going to be in the woods when the Baker
and his wife go there what if the witch
decided to tell him about this curse
tomorrow did she know all this was
happening if she can predict the future
then surely she'll also know that she's
going to die at the end of this movie
look who I found
here take this you mean you found a coat
that is not your husband's but just
happens to be his dad's and it has the
magical beans in it I don't know where
to begin
does your husband not usually have his
own coat is it missing amazing you found
a coat that figures into the plot of
this movie now remind me what am I to
return with yeah those items were not
nearly specific enough to remember a
white cow a red cape a slipper bears
gold and yellow hair you definitely
should have written this grocery list of
common items down I still wish to go to
the fest to go yes yes we know we've
been hearing a complain about it for 14
minutes also why are you running toward
a closing gate right now it's not like
if you get past the gate you can
suddenly go to the festival into the
woods where into the woods to visit my
damn everything known a man is in these
woods I bet there's even a Home Depot in
these woods
no wonder the witch believes so strongly
you can get all these extremely specific
items there forty-two percent of this
movie is the words into the woods deep
within the woods huh sudden returning
narration and why does this movie where
80% of the information is doled out and
expositional songs even bother with a
play narrator Cinderella had planted a
branch at the grave of her mother and
she visited there so often and wept so
much that her tears watered it until he
had become a magnificent tree what do
you know what you wish yeah I wish I
didn't have to live with my cruel
stepmother and stepsisters anymore and
why have you never given me this wish
option until now once again nature magic
gets to dress Anna Kendrick and I'm left
holding two dresses up in the air hello
Anna I'm standing right here
I can only take a few hundred more
rejections before this gets sad suddenly
found herself in a very unusual part of
the woods you mean there's no white cows
pure as gold slippers or hair as yellow
as corn just lying around
is that Johnny goddamn Depp and where
might your grandmother live who cares
why don't you go ahead and eat her now
look at that flesh pink and plump hello
little girl pedophilia song also during
the end of the woods sing along I
imagine they need to do background
checks on all the audience members
before starting the show Johnny Depp's
temptation song to this little girl is
way too pink sexual it's like watching
Jack Nicholson meet Hailee Steinfeld
when you talk him to your meal so she
can't hear him right now in musicals for
granny still not quite certain why the
wolf hasn't eaten Little Red Riding Hood
yet there are no witnesses this is the
perfect scenario dark woods defenseless
meals so go for it already Wow is she
here
does she need to micromanage the Baker's
RPG quest or is it just because the
movie needs an excuse to give Meryl
Streep more seems unnecessary orders but
nice exit this little girl is way too at
ease with all these random people
showing up in the otherwise deserted
forest damn this movie has really got a
subtext problem 7 seconds of sustained
screaming we're gonna find that red guy
you definitely found the red cape you
just realized what a horrible person you
were for trying to steal it Baker's wife
finds her husband in the middle of the
woods with no problem whatsoever
to help I want to press stop on this
stupid movie cow is white this milk pump
bigger these woods anyway like an acre
oh why you be doing with a cow in the
middle of the forest I was going to ask
you the same question until I saw your
wife was Emily Blunt nice work old Chuck
I was hidden sports market which
obviously requires walking through the
woods to get to yeah I know the story of
Jack and the Beanstalk yeah I know this
is basically the story of how he comes
into possession of some magic means but
seriously he actually believes this oh
man they dragged tangled into this
didn't they but little did she know that
the girls lilting voice had caught the
attention of a handsome prince these are
facts that all of us even the
three-year-olds in the audience already
figured out by watching the movie also
what is a handsome prince doing riding
around in the woods anyway surely if
this was a normal thing for him to do he
would have stumbled on Rapunzel way
earlier than this hmm this looks painful
is fuck
tonton I really would like to see if the
handsome prince would try and save
Rapunzel if she wasn't a hot runway
model she was surprised to see the door
standing open even though she exhibited
no surprise at all upon seeing the Walt
and the Baker in the woods how uneasy I
feel perhaps it's all the sweets this
movie simply doesn't trust the
imaginations or intelligence of children
were force-fed every action and feeling
through narration dialogue and singing
it's just like that time I was kicked
out of my first college orgy
by the way why does a human female live
in a tree is this a transitional period
in time where most people live in houses
but a small segment of the population
still prefer the homes of our distant
evolutionary ancestors and how does this
tree not die after hollowing it out
ripping out the ground underneath
candles and a literal tree house that's
a fire hazard little girl should now
immediately know that this isn't a
grandmother obvious wolf granny is
obvious wolf grandmother you're looking
very strange this Red Riding Hood fairy
tale has always relied on the Red Riding
Hood to be a fool moron what big ears
you have his ears aren't even visible in
the shot better to hear you yeah I did
well at least into the woods Little Red
Riding Hood figure this out way before
her written counterpart did
even if I believe that won't actually
swallow to humans whole am I going to
believe for an instant the Baker could
free them with a random stab to the
wolf's stomach he could have and should
have easily killed one of the victims
with that blind stab her rear cargo
Cobra Barlow Gurjeet excuse me my brain
left my head for a second I the Red
Riding Hood nor her grandmother are
covered in icky wolf digestive matter I
should have known better
mother said straight ahead yeah but
couldn't you tell me that without
singing it and he showed me things many
beautiful things that I hadn't thought
to explore he showed you some pretty
flowers and that's about it I guess
that's enough to count as many beautiful
things in whatever year this is when he
said coming with that sickening grin
previously on into the woods
whoops throat is exactly like the Harry
Potter tents with way more room inside
than they seem to have on the outside
also the lining of the wolf's stomach is
made with 1000 thread-count Egyptian
cotton sheets so it's not that bad
really
this is the flashback to something that
happened literally 90 seconds ago and we
had already figured it out on our own
that's bold as it is and we just went
through a lot so she could finally hand
him that cape I mean the singing not the
wolf attack what sort of poets changes a
cow for beans the kind that's clearly
too young but that you sent out to sell
the cow anyway presumably due to
laziness angry mom throws beans which
hit the ground with a flash of magic but
angry mom doesn't see it naturally Bick
without supper for you isn't unlike all
the time though is that really a
punishment this movie assumes you
entered the theatre winking the prince
daunced only with huh thus narrator
keeps showing up after long absences
where on-screen characters provide
plenty of exposition plus we don't want
to give away the surprise of the new
Cinderella movie we have coming up in
three months that will surely be
completely different from the hundred
other adaptations before Anna Kendrick
is frightened and running down the
stairs and I am unable to help due to
some freaking technicality of a
restraining order if the prince knew
where Cinderella was running and it
could really only be one place why did
he bother running up this hill why
didn't he send some of his men out to
the one exit this castle has so that
they could follow her Baker's wife took
no time finding her husband during the
daytime but is still stuck in the woods
around midnight because it's time for
Cinderella to crash into the plot tell
me the prince what was he like he's a
very nice Prince
well glad that information could come by
we have song certainly makes it more
impactful to meet well it was tall we're
talking about Chris Pine know right
that's pure as gold I think it would
have been awesome at the Baker's wife
had run into a person that totally did
not have an item she need it and then
saying something like well that was
pointless sometimes a person in the
woods is just a person in the woods
I guess mr. wake up how the fuck does
Jack even know where the baker is so
when Jack saw this Beanstalk in the wee
hours of the morning he thought I better
climb this thing that goes so far up
into the clouds
you never know Giants with gold might be
up there a big to terrible lady giant
that's racist i Jewish you close to a
giant breasts keeping with the theme of
adults relationships with kids in this
movie also Jack somehow woke up saw a
beanstalk climbed it had an adventure
with a giant stole some stuff climbed
back down and ran into the woods before
his mom woke up but she did it was she
mighty but she did but she might have
dagger chairs I was just about to say
skip and then the witch basically did it
for me searching all night for oh yes I
know exactly who you mean well I'll just
continue riding over here see a sweet
brother and I say rapunzel rapunzel let
down your hair to me it seriously nearly
everything that happens in this movie is
told to us after it happens why her
spine channels his inner Shatner because
that's what Captain Kirk does two actors
power of speech the form i watching
right now you know nothing of the
madness Ruby cautions viewer about the
second hour before the first hour is
even complete both these Prince's are
singing about women we barely get to see
them meet or spend time with and
understand because who needs to see the
story of Cinderella and Rapunzel again
that said why do you even need to see
these guys sing about them if the movie
doesn't even care about their stories
also just a status check this is a song
where two dudes competitively compare
emotional pain at not being with girls
the crushing on despite the fact that
everything and everyone in the woods
appears exactly when they need them the
Baker's wife still hasn't found this
freaking cow because she suddenly needs
to run into Rapunzel is that you at this
hour my friends you did hear a female
voice right that's at the very least the
witch which is what I would have guessed
yes this works the second night of the
festival was thrown into chaos when
Cinderella once again ran from the
prince this is movie doing - Cinderella
it turned a noble girl scared of having
her magic pumpkin secret revealed into
the condom runaway bride jeez with all
this same exact stuff happening two
nights in a row Emily Blunt must've
thought she was filming a weird sequel
to edgerton morrow the world
can be a dangerous place oh but I'm not
going to help you yeah I figured this
movie needed to reboot back to its old
ways
hilarious stumbling upon the cow is
hilarious and on cue the Baker's wife
shows up at the exact moment the Baker
found the cow
it's amazing the Golden Slipper hasn't
fallen out of the sky yet well sure more
sharing I see it's like a metaphor the
literal quest they have in front of them
is so they can have a child the quest
itself is actually a metaphor for being
ready to have a child by the way up in
hate metaphors and movies that bang you
over the head with narration and singing
about things that just happen tell you
what if I ever have to sing a song this
long to get laid then I choose
masturbation asks for Rapunzel's Prince
he returned yet again
Prince is able to climb Rapunzel's tower
despite the massive Rapunzel hair theft
last night
Oscar nomination song also skipped I
used to see the joints toy halt the
story is basically all the unexcited
things your favorite fairytale
characters did when they weren't during
their fairytale stuff jack is a dick to
the end the Beanstalk install came
crashing down jack murders a giant for
his golden coins golden egg and golden
harp and he's supposedly the good guy
killing the giant even though he was
roughly 25 feet from the ground when the
Beanstalk fell according to this shot
and that definitely shouldn't kill the
Giant he spread pitch on the stairs
and I'm caught on all where's well it
means that he cares or it means he's
kind of rapey but it's a woman's
prerogative to figure out what her
barricades to freedom are in a
relationship not mine also why did the
world stop time while she sang this song
but where everything's wrong
Anna Kendrick says the phrase
everything's wrong which is close enough
to make her our honorary fairy godmother
forever and ever amen
I'll just leave him a clue for example a
shoe and then see what he'll do the guy
ordered Cinderella stopping tar in the
stairs why do you still need proof that
he wants you I need that shoe to have a
child that makes no sense
movie decides at the halfway point to
begin caring about what makes sense we
must search immediately the mate
fits this slipper just seeing her with
my own I should do especially since I've
now seen her three nights instead of one
and she's not wearing a mask but sure
I'll keep up this fit the slipper bull
even though there would surely be at
least one woman who has the same size
feet of Cinderella and did I mention
I've seen her face three nights in a row
Prince takes off in pursuit of Maiden
that fits the slipper without even
trying it on the girl he found carrying
the slippers mate mounted the princes
horse unaware of the blood dripping from
the slipper unaware of the blood
dripping from the slipper Prince
continues to let maidens try on the
slipper outside his field of view
because reasons have you no other
daughters only a little stunted kitchen
wench
why even bother mentioning her if you
don't want Cinderella to even have a
chance of winning the slipper now has
the blood of two evil stepsisters
sloshing around in it but I guess
Cinderella's foot is so dirty who cares
about being unsanitary at this point I
would recognize these beautiful eyes
anyway and the general Anna Kendrick
mess up her face but sure foot size and
eyes never lie Cinderella's bouts
swooped down upon the stepsisters heads
as for Rapunzel the witch had banished
her to a swamp I kind of feel like
you're just making all this up as you go
at this point is this live
Rapunzel's banishment spot lines up
perfectly with her blind boy
friends desperate search because this
movie is basically saying magic forest
so anything goes but just Disney magical
love tears cliche and zoo also well I
guess that takes care of the conflict I
was worried about for five seconds why
are you surprised this force is like
really fucking tiny this cow has been
covered with flour didn't get a real
white cow how much more of this bullshit
do I have to endure goddammit Jack's
mother goes racing into the haunted
woods to find it and naturally does so
immediately why did the story even
bother killing the cow it didn't matter
to the plant one whit Jesus Sookie halfa
: that's not technically the right
ingredient because the witch asked for
hair is yellow as corn not hair is
yellow on corn but hey that's a
frightful nitpick
I'm just stupefied that this is what's
going to make this spell work Baker's
wife becomes pregnant without doing any
of the fun stuff just remember youth
serum can be made by combining a Golden
Slipper a red cape corn hair and feeding
it to a zombie cow which produces youth
milk I know I'm trying to figure out why
that's not stupid too but we're going to
get through this I think I just gave
them capable promise everything's so
different this is why you should have
several non woods roots to your home
just in case well I just see always cry
when I hold him this is exactly what my
college girlfriend said to me about my
penis hey would you like a blind girl
staring I guess that's supposed to be
funny but then I'd have to deconstruct
what makes a joke funny and ironically
it wouldn't be funny anymore after that
oh geez cow and exchanges of badger
yes let's retell the story we all saw
then heard again just for the sake of
the Giant alone god damnit ticket Jack
no gun Jack it's okay it's okay
Thomason uncapable promises Rapunzel's
snuck away from the castle to have a
good cry in the tower in which she was
once in prison that makes sense and it
makes sense not only to the witch but to
her prince as well who say to themselves
if I need to find Rapunzel right now
where is the most likely place she'd go
to the place where she was prisoner for
17 years
pointed song about parenthood and
children going off on their own son
sincerely by evil witch who locked her
daughter in a tower and manipulated
every single thing in her entire life
yet again main character runs into
another main character in the woods is
there such a thing as cameos or extras
in this world we have a giant in our
midst when the giant walked through this
part of the woods she watched her step
and didn't destroy anything anything
haben and sat was literally the entire
pitch for this movie tacit adultery
this is ridiculous what am I doing here
I'm in the wrong store free the Baker's
wife would be amazing at cinemasins also
obeyed it's worse than you think there
isn't even a story here in this place
foolishness can happen in the woods it
almost exclusively happens in fact we're
practically in a whole new movie now I
wish they find this bastard Jack and
feed him to the giant already life is
often so unpleasant
this guy is suddenly super pervy
ordering on ray be the what's going on
hey what 79 for auntie the Baker
definitely miscounted since there are
only 40 steps in any one direction in
the woods before you're out of it the
she read of times the characters run
into each other bear that out all the
times they got lost stupidity you look
like the princess but dirty I'm also
confused as to how long it's been since
the giant first came down it's like
they're all living in the
post-apocalypse years after the flood
water supply ran out jack should look
like Mad Max by now I really truly think
the earthquake happened an hour ago in
movie time though right besides the
Baker's wife would be a myth oh we just
said that carry on was he wrong yes
am i mad yes does he miss me was he
suddenly getting bored with me you are
happily married have a child for warmth
and a baker for bread an appearance for
whatever this movie could have been
pretty great if it wasn't rated PG make
this r-rated they could have explored a
lot of themes and made this great
instead it's this meta moment go good
god we've spent a good five minutes on
this out of nowhere Prince kisses the
Baker's wife moment after all that
bullsh the fucking Baker's wife dies
look who I found
oh and what a surprise we didn't see
this moment happen on film sure we'll
spend a nap time with a Baker's wife in
the prince but something actually
plot-related
just tell me about it when it happens
they might as well just make an audio
book for people to pay for in theatres
let go of him when I get into giant why
did she even bother to drag Jack through
here in the first place did you want to
get stopped well they were plus beans
were they oversold Christ Skippy pokey
did the other thing I didn't Jess I did
but God I mean this is argue singing
it's cingulate and frustrating as it
sounds
can't we all just agree that Jack is at
fault here I'm leaving you my
I've never seen a movie so allergic to
story in my life Oh Levine - this movie
that made no sense is now making
infinite negative sense well I guess
she's gone maybe I should've stolen from
the joint maybe I shouldn't have strayed
from the path maybe I shouldn't have
attended the ball maybe Jack shouldn't
stolen from the giant you would leave
your child be happier in the arms of a
princess so what are you doing here son
Baker confronts Darth Vader on Dagobah
because this is one of the final tests
before becoming a Jedi at leavening
bread good friends we need your help now
more than ever yeah we need you to call
the Eagles in on this tell them to stop
being such assholes and help us instead
of Gandalf for a change the birds will
do their part and let's only have to say
about that I shall always love to meet
who ran away and I the faraway Prince I
mean what the hell happened in this
movie it's like a whole section of story
got cut yeah sure he tried to kiss Emily
Blunt who wouldn't but even before then
the prince and Cinderella was separated
so what the cabin it's about your mother
she didn't make more great off-screen
exposition for the movie also are you
telling me that when the steward push
Kirk she actually died from that and
this is how Jack got revenge on the
Giants wife after Jack stole from and
killed her husband oh wait cool she can
come estate but with all that sweet
sweet Baker's money I pull in I can
afford a sudden family of five and a
village just torn apart by a giant
things will be hold right now hey
remember when this movie was a totally
different movie
this forest is old they're young
good day young lady good day mr. wolf
you said in the womb snigger all all of
the whole human race missus got a
spirited cons of men and only to stank
talks in his proper price in the one
with his foot in the other ones face
oh just wonder what
how do you do my name's Gavroche these
are my people here's my patch